joining me now is eric schmidt missouri
attorney general candidate for u.s
senate and texas lieutenant governor dan
patrick um attorney general schmidt you
filed an amicus brief i know in support
of coach kennedy we've had him on the
angle a number of times now what do you
say to these people saying that this
decision
is a separation of church and state
issue
yeah these people have lost their minds
and their real objection is with the
constitution this country was founded on
the idea that people could express their
religious beliefs and the government
will protect that right a god-given
right not infringe upon it and so here
you had a coach uh engaged in voluntary
prayer and the left has lost their minds
that it's now protected and we're led to
believe by the way by these same people
that it's perfectly okay to force your
kids to sit through drag queens story
hour and this woke indoctrination in our
schools they're okay with that they want
to push that but the idea that you
actually have a constitutionally
protected right to engage in prayer is
very affirming that the court you know
issued this opinion today because this
is exactly the right way the
constitution is supposed to protect
these individual rights and the right to
express yourself through prayer is
certainly protected
is a big win
for for religious liberty here today all
right dan on the issue of roe kamala was
asked tonight about federal financial
resources for women who want abortions
watch
what about the idea of financial
resources
some form of voucher for travel for
women seeking abortions in states where
it's not legal you're asking a very
important point making a very important
point which is what are the details are
going to go into ensuring that women
have the ability to actually
travel
without impairment and so this is
something that we are looking at
dan she's talking about i guess helping
women travel out of states like yours
which is currently being sued right by
the aclu uh your reaction
this is a culture of death in this
administration laura
and now they want to give a voucher to
go take the life of a baby you know
through this entire discussion laura the
last couple of days since roe v wade was
overturned i have not heard one person
on the left say anything that seemed to
care about the life of the baby i
haven't heard one person say we wish
every baby was
was born we don't support abortion we
just support choice but we do care about
the babies as well as these mothers i
haven't heard a word they talk about
they talk about these innocent babies in
the womb as if if they're not human as
if they don't even know they don't think
they are it's absolutely sickening this
culture
i mean they don't think they are human
and general schmidt senator warren
wants to carve out spots on federal land
for abortion providers
the hhs secretary javier becerra didn't
rule it out watch
there are a number of conversations on
any number of options that can be out
there we will certainly take a close
look as we made a commitment uh some
time ago months ago as we were planning
for whatever might come from the supreme
court we will take a take a look at
every option to make sure a woman has
access to the care that she needs i mean
general smith is this a pop-up abortion
tents outside of glacier national park
what are we talking about
yeah i mean look justice alito had it
right that the minute the day that the
roe versus wade decision was handed down
it was on a collision course with the
constitution and the court got it right
after 49 years and returned this issue
to the states to the side missouri when
i issued the attorney general opinion
you know moments after that became the
first state to effectively end abortion
and we need to be up unapologetically
pro-life here and the idea that the left
is going to continue to you know you
know come up with these crazy ideas
uh continue to try to intimidate
justices let's not forget and we ought
to have hearings i mean the january 6
hearings right now are a total joke we
ought to actually have hearings about
you know chuck schumer encouraging
violence people actually violating
federal law trying to intimidate
justices to change their minds an
assassination attempt against justice
kavanaugh this is third world banana
republic stuff it's serious but the left
there's no law norm or rule they're not
willing to break to get the desired
outcome now
it's crazy it's an intimidation game and
they're not going to stop until they're
stopped by law enforcement and there's
real repercussions dan we have to get to
the breaking news tonight out of san
antonio speaking of the culture of death
law enforcement is telling fox that at
least 46 migrants
have been found dead in a
tractor-trailer uh more than a dozen
hospitalized i understand there's you
know been three arrests made what can
you tell us tonight this is the cost of
joe biden's open border though i can
tell you that
this is more death on the hands of the
president i can't think of anything
worse
laura
than these
people in that 18 wheeler suffocating
the heat going to 130 degrees or more
trying to climb out desperately
desperately and they died
culture of death whether it's fentanyl
that he allows to come over the border
because he has open borders that kills
our teenagers whether it's these 46
people and it may be more those are in
the hospital are very critical
and the babies that we've talked about
if ever today with this decision handed
down on prayer if ever this nation needs
to climb out of the darkness we are in
of the biden administration now is the
time that we all should be on our knees
and pray
seven second chronicles 7 14 of my
people and we need to pray because
america is in darkness right now well i
think there's a lot of light out there
and we're seeing we're seeing some bad
news but that court decision was a great
great moment for this country it was a
great day good gentlemen great to see
you both hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else